- So when are we finally
going to see a Moesha reboot?
Okay, we see all these reboots
and I was such a Moesha fan.
What, when is this happening?
- You know what it's, it's,
we're still talking about it.
I, I'm so open for it.
I, I want it so badly
and I think just the way the show ended,
it ended on a cliffhanger and I think,
you know, the people that
have supported Moesha
over the years, they,
they want, they want answers
and I feel like it would be
so appropriate to do one.
And I just want everybody that's watching
I'm with it.
I really want to do it.
- Yeah.
So is,
is there a young singer actress
you could see starring in this,
like taking on your part in Moesha?
I don't want to give my part up.
I want to do the reboot.
(laughing)
- I love it.
I love it.
I didn't know if you'd
reboot it a different way,
you know how people keep
rebooting in different ways
and they almost take like a different role
and like somebody else comes up.
I didn't know how y'all would do that,
- Yes.
- but that's cool.
You're like me, you like a lot of jobs.
I love, I love to act.
I love acting and I would just love--
- Oh, I do not.
- to just tell that story
and see how far it could go.